we have an absolutely stunning turn of
events today a veritable treasure trove
of impeachment related documents have
been released by the House Intelligence
Committee and they include among them
text messages exposing that Donald
Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani had his now
indicted henchmen putting ambassador
Murray Ivanovitch under physical
surveillance outside and around the
embassy in Ukraine
check out some of these examples these
are texts text messages between Robert
Hyde a landscaper turned lobbyist who
has donated a bunch of money to Trump
and is running for some position in
Connecticut although we expect that that
will be wrapping up pretty soon he was
once arrested at Donald Trump's
mar-a-lago Resort and brought to a
medical facility for a psych eval he
seems to have been coordinating with Lev
Parnas one of Rudy Giuliani's henchmen
around physical surveillance of
ambassador Murray Ivanovich still trying
to sort it all out check out some of
these text messages this is a Robert
Hyde texting levy arnis that address I
sent you checks out it's next to the
embassy they are willing to help if we
you would like a price suggesting that
he's talking to people near the embassy
who for a price can do whatever it is
Rudy wants done to the Ambassador later
texting updates she will not be moved
special security unit upgraded force on
the compound people are already aware of
the situation my contacts are asking
what is the next step because they
cannot keep going to check people will
start asking questions another one makes
it seem as though they are continuing to
track ivanovich's real-time movements
quote she's next to the embassy not in
the NBC private security been there
since Thursday there's more they will
let me know when she's on the move and
they'll let me know when she's on the
move perfect I mean where if they can
find out correcting that last text
message so we've confirmed that when the
State Department said there were threats
to Marie ivanovich's security they were
right she was being followed around it
just so happens it was Donal
Trump's people through his lawyer and
his lawyers henchmen that were following
around Murray ivanovitch there are
assertions that they had a plan for some
kind of physical violence although those
are merely assertions at this point in
time it almost seems like Rudy Giuliani
should have been arrested or at minimum
at this point forced to come in to
answer questions about this and
undoubtedly should be part of the
upcoming Senate impeachment trial and
this is just one piece of what they have
there is reportedly audio there is
reportedly video that is available with
further incriminating evidence regarding
what was going on with Murray Ivanovich
Republicans want to keep all of this
stuff out of the upcoming Senate
impeachment trial of course it should
all be in the Senate impeachment trial
and we will see ultimately what happens
because the United States is being run
like the mob Donald Trump is president
he wants to bribe and extort Ukraine
into publicly smearing Joe Biden but
there's problems so Donald Trump says
let's fix those problems he gets Rudy
Giuliani his personal attorney who has
no government role not confirmed by the
Senate not elected to anything he gets
Rudy Giuliani to do the dirty work
Rudy Giuliani then says okay let's hire
some henchmen he brings in left Parnas
and Igor Froman and says Murray
Ivanovich is a problem Rudy has publicly
admitted that he worked to get Murray
ivanovitch out of the way that's his
phrase phraseology not mine
so left Parnas says I know what to do
let's get physical surveillance put on
Murray Ivanovich like the mob through
this guy Robert Hyde who has an insane
history and they are tracking her
they're following her around they
seemingly are plotting something not
okay to do to an ambassador we can say
that with certitude at this point even
if we don't have more details the mob is
in the White House they're in the White
House and they are so far going
unpunished Trump impeached in the house
but of course likely to be acquitted in
the Senate so hopefully one of the
things we'll know by tomorrow or maybe
by Friday is what of all of this
treasure trove of information will be
part of the impeachment trial in the
Senate
which witnesses will be subpoenaed to
come in we want to hear from john bolton
we should hear from rudy giuliani
hopefully left Parnas will be
participating it seems he has the goods
and is all of a sudden more than willing
to actually spill them this is getting
insane and we're going to have follow-up
coverage of this on our Instagram
account if you are on Instagram follow
the david pakman show at david pakman
show and while you're there follow me at
David Pakman